you bring up an excellent point about
you know sort of that a to b to c you
know this this defined path there you go
and you accomplish these certain amount
of you know hours or whatever it is to
accomplish something and then you're at
the next level whereas with a creative
career there's not a set path and it's
often self generated in terms of you
have to drum up that sort of noise for
yourself where did you get in your life
where you were able to let go of that
path I i mean i was aware that i didn't
really know where to go with developing
a creative career and I was I was
frightened that I would just set out
somewhere I wouldn't know where I was
going and I could fail but I remember
sitting in an office in the best paid
job I've had and sitting at the desk and
thinking I'm just going to walk out and
it happened twice that I was sitting
there perfectly nice people perfectly
good job and I was just going to walk
out of the office so it was basically um
it was that kind of feeling I was almost
it was almost equal being pulled and
being pushed you know it was that
feeling of I can't I can't put up with
doing this anymore knowing that I want
to do something creative so I'm going to
take a risk i'm going to go out and do
something but it is it is a problem
because I how it kind of feels to me I
are not an entrepreneur as such but it
almost feels to me like every project
you have to start a new business it's a
little one and the product you're
selling is something you don't even you
kind of know some people aren't going to
like and you don't know who's going to
like it and the business could fail the
product may not even work but you know
you've got to start this business and
that's that's one of the scary things I
think it's I think being an artist is
closer to being an entrepreneur than it
is to having a pre these predefined
career paths and you almost have to be
your own taskmaster and if someone's not
good at that then I think it's difficult
are you great at staying on track and
giving yourself a to do this for the day
or however you organize your time dr you
sort of your own you
no maniacal boss in your head it means
sometimes I think that's what it takes
to really push someone I maybe I'm too
hard on myself but I don't think I'm so
great at organizing myself one of the
things I've been fortunate with which
actually I mentioned in the article i
wrote for your website was I've had
predefined performance dates or premiere
dates that has been an absolute
lifesaver because it doesn't matter how
bad a task bus driver I mean obviously
it does but it's got I've got to do it
you know I've got to get this thing done
I've got to get it out there and what
also tends to happen is it gets pretty
publicized after my first few
compositions my commissions for music
the next one was publicized in the
national media as a result of a PR
company so you don't screw up when it's
been publicized in the national media
and you've gotta fix performance day you
don't have to be a good taskmaster
because you're gonna do it you know and
that I did it
you